[Applause]
this is lina rodríguez's facebook account she
had three different profiles and 890
children between the ages of 8 and 13 among her
contacts
these are fragments of a conversation
with one of those children
the conversation is verbatim
and it is in the file
this boy began to  send her intimate photos
until her family found out
the complaint and subsequent investigation
allowed an address to be reached
this was the girl's room
lina rodríguez was actually a
24-year-old adult who had the habit of
doing this with many minors
micaela ortega was 12  years old
when he left to meet his new
facebook friend of the same age as
roig and river he said his name
was he actually met
26 year old jonathan luna
well finally when they caught him
he confessed that he killed her because the girl didn't
want to have sex
he had  four facebook profiles and
1700 women among their contacts
90% were under 13 years of age
these are two different cases of
grooming
an adult contacts a minor
over the internet and through
manipulation or deception leads them to
sexual grounds from talking  from sex
to sharing intimate photos recording it
through the webcam or arranging a
physical encounter
this is grooming it
is happening and it is growing
the question is what are we going to do
because in the meantime the boys are
alone
they finish dinner they go to the room
they close  the door
grabs the computer the cell phone and they
enter a bowling alley
or a disco
think for a second what I just told you
they are in a place full of strangers
and in a context of lack of inhibition
the internet broke the physical barriers
when we are alone in our
room we connect to  Internet We
are not really alone there
are at least two reasons why
we are not addressing the issue or at
least not in the proper way.
The first is that we are sure that
everything that happens on the Internet is virtual.
In fact, we call it that by the world.
virtual
if you look it up in the dictionary
something virtual is something of
apparent existence and not real
and we use that word to refer to the
internet something not real
and that is the problem with grooming that
is real perverted
degenerate adults use the
internet to abuse boys and girls  and they
take advantage, among other things, of the fact that
they and their parents think that what
happens and in reality does not happen a
few years ago with several colleagues
we founded an Argentine cyber-safe NGO
dedicated to raising awareness about
safe browsing on the Internet
in 2013 we participated in  the
meetings in the Chamber of Deputies
where the grooming law was discussed
I remember that for many grooming
was only the previous step to
make a physical encounter with the
boys and have sex with them
but they did not think what happened to the
boys who were exposed  to talk about
sex with an unknowing adult
who shared intimate photos thinking
that another child would see it or even worse
that they were exposing themselves through the webcam
nobody saw that as a violation
I am sure that many of you
make noise to think that a  person can
abuse another without touching it
we are formatted to think so I
don't know why it was the same in my case alone
only a computer security technician
until this happened to me
at the end of 2011
in a small city in the province of
Buenos Aires it was the  The first time I
heard a case
after giving a talk,
I was approached by two parents whose
11-year-old daughter had been groomed by
an adult who had manipulated her into
masturbating in front of the webcam and
had recorded her
and her videos and the  cared for by various
websites
that day the parents tearfully asked us to
give them the recipe to
remove those videos from the internet it
broke my soul and a little changed me
forever being the last disappointment
telling them that it was too late once
a  content is on the internet we already
lost control
since that day when i think about that girl
who got up in the morning and was
seasoned with her family who had seen
her video
and walked to school and
ran into people who had seen her
naked
and arrived  and he played with his friends who
had also seen him
like this life
exposed
of course no one raped his body
but his sexuality had not been abused
clearly we have several different ones to
measure the physical and the digital
and we got angry with social networks
because we get angry with ourselves  it is
more painful and more sincere
and this leads us to the second reason
why we are not dealing
properly with the issue
and that is that we are convinced that
children do not need our help and that they
are clear about it with technology
when I was a child
at some point I  They let me walk
alone to school
after doing it for many years hand in hand with
my parents.
She sat me down. They saw the keys to the
house and they kept me very well.
When we
told you to cross the corner, look
both ways before crossing and
fundamentally do not talk to
strangers,
I was very clear about it walking
and yet the figure of the
responsible adult was there to take care of me.
Knowing how to do something is one thing and another
is  know how to take care of
yourself imagine this situation with me I am 10 or
11 years old I get up in the morning they throw me
the house keys they tell me he is leaving today you
can walk to school
and when I come back late
they tell me oh you don't have to arrive at the
time we told you
and two weeks later when you pass you know that you
have to use the corners and look
both ways before crossing
and two years later
and don't talk to strangers
it sounds ridiculous not
that ridiculous we behave with
technology we
give kids full access  and
we see if one day sooner than
later they learn how to take care of themselves
one thing is knowing how to do something another thing
is knowing how to take care of themselves
in the same line when we go to talks
for parents it is very common for them to tell us
that they are not interested in
technology that they are not interested in  The
social networks
always asked him if his children are interested
as adults. Approaching technology or not
is the same as that we
only approach children, the Internet is part of
their lives,
technology forces us to rethink the
relationship between adults and minors,
education.  It was always based on
two pillars: experience and
knowledge,
as we do then to teach
safe Internet browsing when we don't
have any of this
today as adults we have to guide
children in areas that we often don't
know and that for them are much more
friendly,
so it is impossible to find an
answer without doing new things that make us
uncomfortable that we are not used to,
many of you will think that this
is easy for me because I am relatively young
and for the most part it was like that
until last year when I felt the
heavy years on my shoulders
the first time.
Once I opened the
snapshot, I
didn't understand anything at all. It
seems to me like an unnecessary and useless social network. It
seems like a
camera. It didn't have a menu with
options.
It was the first time I felt the abyss
that sometimes exists between children and
adults,
but at the same time.  it was the opportunity to
do the right thing to make
me uncomfortable and force myself I
had felt that never in my life and
muzzles napt chad but then I asked
my teenage cousin to tell me how
she used it
but also why she used it she wants
fun
we had a beautiful talk she showed me her
snapshot  He told me things we got closer we laughed
today I use it I
don't know if very well but the most important thing
is that I know him and that I understand him
the key was to encourage me to get out of the
initial shock to launch myself into doing something
new
something new today we have the opportunity to
create new  dialogues
what is the last application you
downloaded what social network are you
communicating with your friends what kind of
information is uploading
some stranger I try to talk to you we
can have these conversations
boys and adults
we all have to force ourselves right here
there are many young people
who are us  listening
many times when we give talks in
schools or through social networks
the kids ask us or tell us
things that they have not dared to tell
their parents or their teachers yet to us
who don't even know us
these kids have to know
what the  risks of browsing the
internet
how to take care of yourself but fundamentally that
like almost everything else when they are
children they can learn it from any
adult
safe browsing on the internet has
to be a topic of conversation in every
home and in every classroom in the country
in a survey that  we did this year
15 percent of schools reported
knowing cases of grooming at their
institution
and the number is growing
technology has changed all aspects
of our lives including the risks
we face and how we take care of ourselves
and grooming i am not going to show you  the
most painful way
messing with the boys
let's get involved to avoid it
the solution starts in a place as
simple as this talk about it
thank you very much